I'll be back when I read the album back  line I said to Jim Cameron I said to me  it sounds weird when I say ow  I'll be back as it says how would you  say and I say I will be back and he says  no because uh I very casually said you  know Jim I say I would just rather say  you know I will be back and I thought  this was going to go right by and he  would say yeah say whatever you want to  know I said machine we're not  abbreviated and this is no no just say  I'll be back as it is but it's better I  will be back this is what does the  goddamn script say and I said scriptures  I'll be back and the assistant say the  [ __ ] line okay I mean I don't correct  your acting so don't correct my [ __ ]  writing you should know that you never  know when you do a movie which of the  lines are going to be repeated out there  later on I mean the audience speaks that  the fans speak that so when I said I'll  be back I had no idea that this line  ever will be repeated by anybody